[موسيقى]
حياته مع رفيده ياسين على العربيه
انا رفيده ياسين وهذه هي حياتهم على
العربيه بودكاست واليوم رحله الى مكان
غريب ومختلف جدا حيث تعيش قبائل البندق في
ولايه اوريستا بالهند وبالضم ولايه قريسه
العدد الاكبر من السكان اللي بينتموا
للقبائل الاصليه في المنطقه في المنطقه
بتحديدا بتعيش حوالي 15 قبيله
مجموعات بتعتمد على اللغه خاصه بهم بتختلف
كليا عن كل اللغات المعتمده في الهند
وبترجع جذور اللغه دي للعصور الحجريه وفقا
مستكشفين وخبره في المنطقه
وبالتالي شعب البندق عندهم عاداتهم الخاصه
المختلفه تمام الاختلاف عن عادات الهنود
النساء في القبيله دي هن اللواتي يعملن
على فلاحه الارض وحصده وبرده بيتم
الاعتماد عليهن في صناعه الادوات
والحلاء وادوات الزينه بصوره عامه النساء
بتذهب في مجموعات الى السوق الاقرب في
القريه المجاوره
وبيجلس على الارض بعيدا عن النساء
الاخريات اللي بيرتدوا الساري الهندي
قرب الجدران بتتم عمليه مقايده بتحصل فيها
نساء الباندو على السمك المجفف وبعض
الزيوت مقابل حبوب الفول والبندوره اما
رجال فبيكونوا جالسين على بعض بيراقبوا
مهاره النساء في التفاوض والمتاجرات وممكن
في تلك الحاله يقوم الرجال بانتقاء العروس
القادره وفق مهارات في التفاوض او في كسب
الرزق وتحقيق مصادر دخله اكبر من كما
واسرتها الرجال بيستخدموا القوس والفاس في
الصياده من الثعالب والغزلان وديمه مهاره
بتتميز بها او بيتميز بها بصوره عامه كل
رجال هذه القبيله وبيتم تعليم الصبيان منذ
نعومه اظافرهم مهارات الصيد المختلفه
رجال البندق وكانوا اساسا من المحاربين
وبيقيموا جمعات رجاليه بيقوموا فيها
بالتدريب حتى لا يفقد مهاراتهم على القتال
بندق ليس الاسم الحقيقي لهذا الشعب وفق ما
يتردد في يطلق عليهم ايضا اسم ريمو من
الطقوس الغريبه جدا والمدهشه عند شعب
البندق انه من العار ان يموت الرجل بسبب
مرض او حادث لانه حسب اعتقادهم كرامه
الرجل بتفرض عليه وانه يلاقي حدفه من خلال
معركه او قتال خلال الدفاع عن نفسه او عن
اهله واسرته وقبيلته وارضه فقط عدد سكان
الباندا غير معروف بشكل محدد ولكن بيتردد
انه بتتراوح اعداد وما بين 4,500 و 5000
نسمه بيتوزعه على ثمانيه قرى في تلك
المناطق ومن ابرز عاداتهم الاخرى انهم
بيتخلوا مؤقتا عن اسلحه لما بيغادروا
التوم ليتوجه الى الاسواق في القرى
المجاوره وده منهم تاثير للدلاله برمزيه
سلميتهم ولعدم اخافه الاسر والنساء
والاطفال والكبار من المجتمعات الاخرى اذا
العنوان الابرز لهذا الشعب هو ان يتم نشر
السلام في مناطقم
الرجال ما بتميزوا كثير من ناحيه اللباس
عن القبائل الاخرى اما النساء البندق
فبيتميز باناقه شديده جدا بتمتعوا باناقه
فريده لباسم مكون من الزينه والحلى بشكل
اساسي اللي بتقوم السيدات بنفسهم بالعمل
عليها
وده بيكون من الياس الزينه تبدا من راس
المراه باطواق من الخرز الى اطواق في
العنق ذات اللون الفضي والاطواق الفضيه دي
بتميز النساء وبتكون رمز الانوثه والجمال
والاستقلاليه والحريه والمساواه والاجتهاد
في العمل وهم الشعب مرح ومتفائل وايضا
بيعيشوا في تجمعات بيحرص فيها على جلسات
السمر واقامه المناسبات في اجواء اسريه
احتفاليه لطيفه في تجمعات بتكون في البيوت
المبنيه داخل منازل وبيكون اسمها سندي
بورن وده مكان مخصص للتشاور بين الرجال
بيتم جلوسهم فيه عبر دائره وبتكون الدائره
دي معموله من الحجاره المسطحه تحت ظل
النخيل شهر ابريل عنده خصوصيته عند البندق
وهو مخصص لاعيادهم وبدوبوا فيه الصيادين
الادغال من دون توقف على الاطلاق قديما
كان يعتادوا على صيد وفير من الغزلان
والضباع والفهود وبتم التمييز بين الرجال
بالشجاعه بناءا على الرقم اللي يبيعودوا
به من نصطاده في ذلك اليوم
الان مؤخرا بسبب تقلص مساحات الغابه على
حساب الاراضي الزراعيه فكثيرا ما يعود
البوندو من دون اي فريسه ووقتها بتكون
الاسر تشعر باحباط وكانه لما الاسره او
رجل القادم من مكان بعيد لم يحصل على شيء
ولم ياتيهم بما ينتظر له لكن يبقى الامل
على تشجيعهم على انه مرات القادمه يمكن ان
يعود فيها بما ينتظرون الباوند بيرفض اي
سلطه عليهم المساوا عندهم شيء اساسي طبيعي
سواء من ناحيه السلطه او الثروه وجميع
البيوت عندهم متشابهه يعني الاسر بتحرص
على انه تكون المستويات متقاربه حتى لا
تكون هناك اي ضغينه بين الناس ولا يشعر
الفروق بينه وبين بعضهم البعض بس هناك شخص
بيدعى
هو بمثابه منسق داخل هذا المجتمع واذا كان
يتراس احيانا المداولات الصباحيه
والدلع يعني ابدا ان المساحه المعطله تمكن
من اصدار الاوامر وفي احسن الحالات بيتمتع
الشخص ده ببعض الاحترام داخل المجتمع لكن
قليل منهم اللي بيتجراؤوا على احداث
مخالفات يعني دي منحه مجتمعيه قد تمنح وقد
تمنع بناء على سلوك الشخص وتم تقديره وفقا
يتصرفاته واحترام للاخر
البندق من الشعوب الاسيويه اللي ما تاثرت
ابدا بالثقافه الهندوسيه هم معتدون
بانفسهم جدا وبيرفض اي ثقافه او اي شيء
دخيل عليهم بعيد عن عاداتهم وتقاليدهم
ومجتمع ايا كان مصدره وده رغم انه على
البعض بيصفهم بالتعالي او الغرور الا انهم
بيروا ان ده مصدر فخر لهم
الشعور بالانتماء
لثقافتهم ولعاداتهم ولما يحملون معهم عبر
الاجيال من تقاليد عادات يمكن تكون خلجت
خلافات بينهم وبين بعض من يسرروا على فرد
ثقافتهم على الاخرين بس هم ضلوا على مر
السنوات متمسكين بكل ما يحملون من ثقافه
ومن اثره جاءوا به عبر الاجيال ببساطه لان
هذه هي حياتها
[موسيقى]